this is what a so-called bomb Cyclone
looks like in time lapse it's timing
could scarcely have been worse
as America mobilizes in the run-up to
Christmas Arctic conditions are blowing
through the country
more than 200 million people are subject
to some form of weather warning
last night I had to bring in the
National Guard
the conditions the blinding snow the
zero visibility
absolute whiteouts it may go down as one
of the worst in history
thousands of flights have been canceled
planes that have taken to the air have
had to negotiate stormy conditions
the winds heavy snow and flooding have
stalled travel by land too
this was part of a road washed away in
May
and this was the scene on the Ohio
Turnpike where several people died after
50 Vehicles were involved in a collision
one Ohio sheriff ventured onto Twitter
to post a health warning on venturing
outside
we got several areas that are
still impassable
stay home let the plow Crews get their
stuff done deputies worked through the
night with zero visibility and darkness
which made things worse
these conditions are causing problems
with power
tens of millions of people are without
it as the foam Cyclone Battles Through
would-be immigrants stuck on the
southern border and experiencing
temperatures really witnessed there
in the nation's capital Washington DC
members of the public have joined
charities in providing food and clothing
to homeless people
all the help they can get this is no
joke and it's happening all everywhere
these people they still human so-called
hypothermia shelters have been opened
here around the country to libraries and
police stations are doubling as warming
centers as authorities scramble to find
emergency accommodation if you don't
expose yourself off to the elements
Beyond which you can tolerate you get in
a sleeping bag or under the many
blankets they give away in this park or
under a pile of clothes
but you got to know your limits I know
we're done in the teens but I'm not
looking forward to Sub-Zero
quiet
um
I value my life
in these particularly cold temperatures
there is concern across the board in
places with power outages and there are
many of them people with roofs over the
head are being advised to seek shelter
not to assume that well that's a heat
Source they will get through the night
in Maine trees felt by the Christmas
Storms forced onto the road a flock of
turkeys what else what next is the
question here from extreme weather that
has brought extreme challenges James
Matthews Sky News in Washington